[Musique]
ah si j'avais la solution pour pas me
transformer en glaçon mon amour quand tu
n'es pas là
[Musique]
je ne reconnais pas je me reconnais pas
je me reconnais pas
des machous de sur ma peau laisse une
trace un oripeaux comment veux tu que je
m'en lasse
encore une absence
ai-je eu très peur aulas et envie de
vous entendre pierre vavasseur bonjour
bonjour merci pour le cadeau c'est une
chanson calme et photographe enregistré
quand on faisait le tour de france de la
france festive encore qu'ils étaient en
voiture c'est très marrant et non jouer
bonjour vous voyez pas ce que parce que
nathalie wolf qui est là vous connaissez
comme comme écrivain évidemment on peut
rappeler un pas de danse on peut
rappeler recommencer hop rap et un
manque d'amour elle vous que c'est
peut-être comme quoi tu
oui un avec le recueil tes yeux plus
qu'apporte du monde je connaissais
évidemment comme journaliste comme
traditionnelles vous vous dire toutes
les semaines dans le parisien week end
comme un amoureux des livres
évidemment parce que vous êtes un vrai
amoureux des livres et d'ailleurs il va
falloir qu'on parle du blog que vous
allez public que vous allez mettre au
monde si je peux dire dans quelques dans
quelques semaines c'est ça oui c'est ça
le plus tôt possible et qui s'appelle et
qui s'appelle des minutes de lumière en
plus voilà presque pour moi la
littérature c'est 10 minutes de lumière
en plus dans la journée comme j'ai vu
comment on était en hiver on est
toujours d'ailleurs et que moi chaque
matin d'hiver je me lève en disant bon
aujourd'hui deux minutes de lumière en
plus le sénégal est transformé le de
hand et des métiers de l'énergie cre
mais alors nappes et limite sa vie par
une forte et clairement ça par contre ça
il écrit il joue de la guitare mois ci
[Rires]
je suis accompagné par quelqu'un de chef
de cité qui est marianne charlotte gens
bougeaient requête au violoncelle et qui
fait que ces petites gens me prennent
tout d'un coup une heure une dimension
une profondeur que je me fais plaisir
il vous produisez malheureusement
actuellement c'est un peu plus compliqué
de se produire sur scène
alors on va refaire avec avec pierre un
peu on va revenir un tout petit pas en
arrière se pencher sur l'année 2020 sur
le iiie ya d'abord peut-être un écrivain
dont vous voulez parler et qui a été un
des gros gros succès de 2020 c'est joël
dicaire avec l'énigme de la chambre 622
oui je vais le dic est requis et qui a
émergé six peut dire qui s'est installée
dans le paysage littéraire en 2012 avec
la sphère québec éric hébert et qui
avait fait 5 millions oui depuis il a
vendu 5 millions de romans et des
exemplaires de son de ses romans barrick
a bear il est revenu
j'allais dire à la mauvaise à nîmes
c'est le seul qui a tiré son épingle du
jeu
les marrons du feu comme pourrait dire
avec ce roman qui est sortie qui n'est
pas sorti mecs énormément dû saisir
quelle pas sorti comme pour tous les les
auteurs qui n'ont pas vraiment pu le
défendre dans les salons ou dans les
librairies etc mais qui a qui s'est
imposé immédiatement y compris en europe
qui est don unique de la chambre 600 m2
d'histoire d'un crime qui s'est déroulée
dans une chambre d'hôtel à genève dans
un pré n'est évidemment maintenant notre
ami notre ami ticker est abonnée au
palace non maîtrise en présentant le
fils dans le ski
et donc comme il ya eu un crime parce
que dans cette chambre la chambre 122
n'existe alors ce qui est passionnant
avec tati cas moi ça m'a toujours plu
avec lui c'est que il réinvente quelque
chose j'aime bien les gens qui vont
cherche qu il trouve un nouveau chemin
dans le col à moi je suis pas très polar
mais s'assainit du dollar ni la
psychologie c'est juste une nouvelle à
nouveau département sur la géographie de
la littérature et alors ils nous
expliquent déjà qu'il ya un meurtre
et on sait est le seul truc qui
pensaient pas vos fonds qui a été tué et
ça c'est grandiose
et sur ces choses là il va se promener
dans genève qui connaît bien et il va
inventer des personnages qui sont qui
ont des noms d'ailleurs totalement
totalement formidable moi j'aime bien le
personnage s'appelle tarnos gaulle et
ils inventent il un grand titre et un
univers qui plaît aux gens est qui et
qui voit là et ils comment dire qu'il
n'est pas fait de rebondissements de
doubles saltos et tout ça et j'ai
simplement fait d'une technique dudit
huilage de phrases si je puis dire qui
fait qu'on va jusqu'au bout avec le même
la même envie de tourner les pages et et
voilà c'est moi il m'a rallier à sa
chapelle
ça y est essayez un type qui a beaucoup
de charme et de ce cher voulons le
retrouve dans ses livres motally oui
vous voulez aussi nous nous parlait
d'une nouvelle maison d'édition la
maison d'édition mis à les barreaux donc
je crois dirigé jeudi à 30 ans du temps
où durant vos catalogues d'ailleurs mais
betty mialet et bernard barrault qui
était avant chez audiard était dans l'
dans la galaxie si je puis dire robert
laffont sont partis et ont créé leur
maison d'édition et se voulait en parler
parce que c'est pas tous les jours
une maison d'édition well jours et ça
c'est sûr et son ensemble enfin ça
déborde maintenant sur 2021 avec
beaucoup de livres ils ont publié khadra
ils vont publier un nouveau une nouvelle
un nouveau drame au romancier comme andy
s'appelle frédéric verreault et eux et
je trouve qu'il faut leur faire signe
parce que ces grands lorsqu'elle très
amusant c'est que si vous avez si vous
allez peut-être de l'odéon maintenant on
a à la fois fermes à riom on a le
dilettante et on a de nouvelles maisons
mire les barreaux et qui vont divan qui
vont à mon avis installé très vite dans
la presse et qui ont démarré en mettant
sur orbite baudelaire grâce à jean teulé
et je voulais redire à quel point ce
livre qui montre un baudelaire hun sen
jaillir plus incendié quinson d'hyères
tout à fait c'est la face ceux de la
face cachée c'est de la face noire de
baudelaire et gray vraiment un grand
livre
il a un talent des robots pour revisiter
l'histoire vont appeler à chaque fois
totalement mes essais enivre on irait
les moules et dont les séquelles que les
personnages étaient présents quoi alors
on va passer à la rentrée littéraire est
votre premier coup de coeur et bien
c'est pour une historienne se souvient
de son fameux échange des princesses qui
est devenu ensuite une formidable
romancière chantal thomas qui d'ailleurs
vient d'entrer à l'académie française au
fauteuil de jean d'ormesson
ah oui alors en plus ça tombe bien elles
le méritent vraiment moi je suis pas je
ne sais pas si l'académie française est
quelque chose dont elle rêvait mais au
moins que dix fois c'est bien d'abord ça
fait une femme de plus mais surtout ce
que je voudrais dire dans ce livre je
voudrais avant même de
de dire de quoi ça parle tout à l'heure
marie-hélène lafon parlait d'être à
l'établi du vous lui demandiez aussi un
écrivain c'est un style mais mais
comment dire chantal thomas c'est une
écriture qui pour moi me touche au sens
propre du terme elle mais je suis
fatigué par son écriture yeux ce que je
veux dire c'est quelqu'un qui a inventé
la sensualité dans les phrases comme
dicaire inventer un autre univers pour
rentrer dans le polar réinvente une
sorte de de sensualité de peau de satin
de l'écriture est là elle raconte
et elle part sur trois thèmes donc de
sable et de neige le sable du cap ferret
où elle a les a passé ses années
d'enfance et d'adolescence en vacances
et puis la neige du saf ont acquis au
taux où elles seront à la fin du livre
et il ya trois axes rial son père qui va
mourir
quarante trois ans je crois alors
qu'elle en a 17 il y à son enfance avec
des photos en noir et blanc de l'enfance
et puis ce japon qui pour elle est le
relais du silence intérieur en fait
autour de ça elle organise une
trajectoire d'une beauté folle qui
mérite d'être regardée sur nos
bibliothèques bien en vue pour qu'on se
souvienne que nous avons en france
énormément de grands écrivains et cette
grandeur du vin qui est son fils thomas
alors il ya un autre écrivain qui a fait
aussi son chemin et aussi inventé une
sorte de style littéraire depuis la
première gorgée de bière c'est philippe
delerm dont le dernier livre la vie au
relief sort surtout justin c'est au
seuil
oui absolument et alors là c'est
intéressant parce que le mot relief
électrique delerm
on l'attend pas trop je veux juste que
c'est lui en relief france de l'aude
jusqu'à présent il nous a fait de
l'aquarelle on dit que c'est le plus
impressionniste de nos de nos écrivains
mais c'est aussi un aquarelliste alors
il mais il met peu de couleur dans son
comment il me fait trop penser aux ailes
des papillons canton malheureusement on
les a touchés et qu'ils nous laissent
une trace sur des doigts fait une trace
de couleur sur les doigts d'honneur mais
jusqu'à présent il a remis sur le métier
ou l'établi comme dira encore
marie-hélène lafon le le le même ouvrage
on sait qu'il est capable écrit sur
l'infime sur l'éphémère presque résolu à
redon le presque rien et est là aussi il
arrive quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup
chez certaines personnes
c'est que ces sens eux se connectent
ceux des gestes un ouvrier suis
quasiment sûr un latin de loup c'est
sans se connectent mais comme si on
avait branché la halle à la lumière de
la de la buanderie sur les cuisines
c'est à dire que lui y sont les couleurs
vous voyez il est toujours connecté pour
aller plus haut plus loin dans l'âme
dans dans la proche des choses est de
l'avenir est là pourquoi relief j'ai un
peu réfléchi que je me suis dit mais en
fait c'est parce qu'ils offrent une
augmente son espace et ils augmentent
ils augmentent les les notions qui font
que les sentiments qui nous racontent et
sensations sont cette fois remise dans
leur contexte
c'est à dire qu'on tout d'un coup on
avait avec son grand oncle à des
rencontres d'athlétisme à un moment
donné il l'est dans un cinéma où il va
revoir le mans 66 sélections frère qui
depuis a disparu enfin bref il replace
tout ça il repère tout ça donc dans ses
souvenirs en ouvrant toutes les portes
et c'est ça le relief en fait c'est que
ce n'est plus simplement une une
commande il ya quelque chose qui passe
comme une hirondelle et qui va décliner
divin
comté s'est aussi des moments de sa vie
et je trouve que c'est un c'est un de
ses meilleurs livres un des plus grands
de l'herbe alors de 7 bureaux savalas à
la biographie nous reste moins d'une
minute alors par l'ennemi donc dû du
dernier mip donc dan fante à jeûner
l'unique maria casarès qu'on a indiqué
qu'avec sa correspondance avec camus
évidemment aka mules et puis surtout
alors je vais lui ce qui nous reste
moins d'une minute on va parler d'amour
c'est évidemment c'est une femme qui
brûle en permanence
c'est une femme en rouge et noir je
connais bien l'auteur fait aussi une
femme en rouge et noir c'est bien de
voir que ces deux hommes se rencontrent
mais c'est le trio d amour entre jean
servais l'acteur s'était burton burton
taylor que gérard philipe qu'elle fait
parfois souffrir
et puis albert camus c'est à mouvementer
là tous ont le coeur du livre je peux
vous dire que quand vous ouvrez solide
n'oublierai pas non plus comme les
précédents ligny maria maria callas
merci infiniment pierre vavasseur alors
le blog ça s'appellera des minutes de
lumière plus est est vécue les on dit
qu'il est là vous venez de vous en
reparler un avec très grand plaisir mais
en tout cas je suis très heureux que
vous m'ayez fait signe merci beaucoup
pierre versé beaucoup pierre lecerf
merci beaucoup de talibans et à très
vite sur un nouveau jeu de lecture non
merci merci
[Musique]